if you're like me and you didn't manage
to swipe an early copy of no man's sky
then you still might be wondering what
exactly you will be doing in this space
faring exploration game in a blog post
Shaun Murray has detailed some of the
things you will be doing in order to
manage expectations and clarify the
nature of the game according to the blog
post some of the things you will
definitely be doing are exploring a
universe of procedurally generated
worlds with beautiful creatures trading
with NPCs combat against robots mechs
and cool space battles and surviving and
crafting in a universe size sandbox if
you're expecting a game where you could
pilot freighters engage in PvP combat
and build civilizations no man's sky is
not the game you've been waiting for but
Murray goes on to say that these things
could be coming in future updates if
you've heard anything about no man skies
first update and you probably know that
this update alone is adding a loft you
can check out a detailed list on
gamespot but beware of spoilers Murray
concluded the blog post by saying this
game is not for everyone it's a weird
game it's a niche game and it's a very
very chill game no man's sky launches
for ps4 on August ninth and for PC on
August twelfth for more on no man's sky
make sure to keep those spaceships doc
dick gamespot